surah maidah a district of the Ethiopian
capital is better known for its huge
garment market than for skateboarding
but that's changing Israel dejan a
founded the Mugabe skate project Mugabe
is a nam hot egg word meaning someone
who gives life to others the main focus
is to help the kids you know understand
the wooden power strength so I always
wanted to focus on no matter how big or
small what we have just like when we
focus on what we have and use it for
positive that makes a piggyback
positivity is more than welcome in this
neighborhood of roughly 10,000 where
poverty is widespread and young people
are easily lured into petty crime kids
get involved in you know a group fight
or like I'm stealing you know just like
especially and they like run the teenage
years that became a problem to end up
being in the trouble the maccabi skate
project keeps the youngsters out of
trouble Israel finances most of the
project himself skateboarding offers
useful life lessons for kids whoever
falls down learns to get right back up
again that's helping 17 year old Lucas
ila we sink his future my guys give come
again before i started at maccabi skate
i was just hanging around the
neighborhood not doing much but now i'm
learning some positive values but amber
zoo negara cinto morado when youth
changed their attitudes people learn to
trust the skateboarding community girls
are joining in too
they get support and encouragement from
Israel's sister moluccan who campaigns
for women's rights in Ethiopia we talk
about we are equal like boy and girl we
have the same potential usually the
girls stay at home and their family want
them to to white inside home like
cooking washing dish not more so the
project is also about sharing the
burdens of everyday chores in the
community today it's a make somebody
happy day and we are actually going to
help the ladies face the water so we
just took their water jar and we are
going to fetch a water for them water is
scarce in Ethiopia especially during the
dry season sometimes people have to
stand in line for an hour until it's
their turn at the tap BAM luck [ __ ]
who's been with mega beasts gate since
he was 12 texts a long wait in stride
look I'm order cuz it bad before I
didn't care about anybody else in the
community but now I help people and I've
changed
the youth of cheryl mehta see Israel
dejan a as a role model he hopes to
expand his skate park beyond Addis Ababa
and make the sport popular all across
Ethiopia